cocaine has been found at the White
House and of course this is triggering
everybody that you can imagine would be
triggered let's first start with the
facts and then we'll go on to the
commentary Politico reports suspicious
powder found at the White House when
Biden was gone was cocaine was cocaine
according to Associated Press sources
Secret Service agents were doing routine
rounds on Saturday uh Sunday when they
found the white powder in an area
accessible to tour groups not in any
particular West Wing office the White
House was briefly evacuated Sunday
evening Biden wasn't there he was at
Camp David and preliminary tests showed
it was cocaine according to law
enforcement Secret Service agents were
doing rounds they found the powder in
this area
um the officials are not authorized to
discuss the investigation there was an
evacuation at 8 45. now you might say
why would you evacuate for coke before
they knew it was coke they thought it
could be Anthrax or who knows what it
might have been
um they did a rapid test and it was
indeed cocaine it was uh the White House
reopened and that is it now we're going
to be going through some of the typical
reactions from the right and this
includes it was Hunter Biden imagine if
this happened under Trump
Etc I want to just put out there I
received a bunch of emails from people
saying David you're not going to cover
this you're scared to cover this it's
the typical thing if a story doesn't go
with your narrative you ignore it what
narrative have I ever stated that this
would contradict have I been have I
spent the last 10 years saying folks
there are no drugs at the White House
and now cocaine at the White House has
destroyed my narrative but I don't know
why you're thinking I would ignore this
story important
the area is accessible to tour groups
it's an area where people from the
public walk through it makes it a much
less interesting story if this was found
in you know the the personal residence
of Joe Biden then it might be a more
interesting story although maybe it
wouldn't be I don't know but the
reaction from the right-wing extremists
has been extreme but also sadly
predictable and we're going to talk
about it in the next segment for now I
do want to tell you about Donald Trump's
reaction to the cocaine in the White
House one of our sponsors is zipix
nicotine toothpicks don't you think it's
time you stopped putting smoke and vape
oils in your lungs zippix toothpicks are
a convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to zipx
toothpicks.com today save 10 with the
code pacman10 at checkout just remember
you must be 21 or older to order the
link is down below